so let's get back to the game and the
game is between look at that Queen age
five Queen age five is being played this
is called the patzers opening for those
who don't know even on our YouTube
channel we actually have a video on this
Queen h5 the Pats are attack that's a
lot of people call this you just go for
checkmate in four moves so trolling or
being serious I'm not sure I'll let you
guys decide but it it's it's a tricky
line we've actually covered it on the
channel that is the first time this
event Magnus Carlsen has been faced with
the checkmate threat from the opening
don't think you see that every day and
White has spent in no time I believe
he's by this opening many times in the
past she seems very comfortable he's
playing he's playing the theoretical
moves this is still theory and he's up
thirty Seconds
we'll see if it pays off once again the
first checkmate threat on crossing right
from the opening Bishop c4 you know
that's sort of the pre move maybe the
pre move attack too if your opponent pre
moves think I made it you know keeps
people honest in bullet that might
actually work in bullet you play E for
they play e5 you play Bishop c4 they
play let's say 96 and you you play Queen
f3 or Queen h5 and if they pre move
Knight f6 end up getting checkmated so
I'm bullet I've seen people lose like
that but in blitz against Magnus not so
easy so easy
hey even if you lose you're known as the
guy who went for the form of checkmate
against Magnus by the way he car
Nakamura supply this opening in a
classical game as well so it's not as
obscure as it may seem so Magnus has the
two bishops opposite side castling he's
looking into a counter-attack on the
queenside white for his part wants to
play maybe each 493 and h5 and
breakthrough on the edge fell defy oh I
like this b5 CB 5 and d5 things are
really sharpening up here onboard one
but this is a very parish I mean this is
a very double-edged position this is
definitely ssin you can go wrong with
either color Magnus is going to have to
handle this with extreme care and he I
mean he's playing principle he's just
counter attacking he asked it because
otherwise white will get grabbed the
initiative very quickly
so after BC six d4 Knight a4 maybe
what's going on here what is going on so
if you take here
d4 on much of d4 is the move but you
know maybe you take here if you take
your Knight takes e4 and he to thing
that's the idea okay so that's what
White's thinking about you take on c6 I
take on you for and your knight is under
attack and you have to defend it to and
remember with two bishops open positions
or what you want to strive for so Magnus
is feeling very confident that if you
can have this sort of open position open
battle that his bishops will come out
ahead looking like a nice center over
here looking like a nice Center 94 maybe
wants to jump to c5 wants to get rid of
those bishops ASAP
take care I play 95 and I want to win
your Bishop air roll champion Carlson
she's got a 1/2 point lead on the field
right now
so still everything to play for
and another big game this round is
Benjamin book again see Cara Nakamura
Nakamura was up a minute box King is
sort of exposed but it is an endgame
materials even white even has the
outside passed pawn anything could
happen here is we're keeping an eye out
on that because Benjamin Bach is in
second place and he's one of the few
people if you guys left who could
realistically surpass Magnus or catch up
to him
Magnus here went for Queen b5 Queen
takes b5 at rook c8 and he says that
this endgame is good for black that's
what Magnus is saying that this is a
good endgame for black what do you guys
think
rook d3 blocks got some really ugly
double e pawns but the benefit of those
W pawns is you can double on the F file
this pawn is sort of soft the pawns are
on the wrong color for black in some
ways but the F file might be weak so I
think my name is binding WF I'll play
Bishop h6 maybe b4 first maybe be four
and a-five okay he does this Carlson is
going to double on the F file keep these
rooks passive on d3 and f1 we're going
to see a technical display here whether
it it pays off I'm not sure but Magnus
wants to go into this endgame he's got
his own weaknesses though that's
something we haven't seen too much he's
got his own weaknesses over here and c3
I mean you can find yourself lost in
some of these n games that the material
is even and in some is black as a worst
pawn structure so Colin's going to have
to come up with something here because
this is n game he might even find
himself on the white side up sometimes
playing against this and that but piling
on some some decent pressure here on the
C file
still looking for breakthrough I agree
with this decision you don't want to
trade you need to defend d4 a4 okay and
you think can happen here is opponent
playing very well even on the clock and
fighting and fighting hard pretty sure
his opponent is a teenage French
international master move e5
so now decisions have to be made we got
some real tension in the center I don't
think you can take on d4 because I look
d7 and after Bishop c3 I have b4 and
you're going to lose a piece so tactics
are in favor of white and a line maybe
you should just take here first
the economy 4 and then maybe try to go
for something like that I'm not sure
some calculation is taking a bit too
much time here though he took 20 seconds
on that you had to play bit quicker
can't get this long time with some big
decisions to be made now he's going for
because there's no p4 but after here
bishop c3 Knight f4 rook d2
it's wide up upon here there's no before
he calculated he's like I'm up upon
rickety - now this doesn't mean it's a
great pun this is weak this is weak
kingless vulnerable
everything is pinned but upon Oh night
here so now 90 to a ninety two white
offers a draw why is now offered to draw
up upon he wants to see what Magnus does
I like that draw for long time trying to
confuse your opponent plus your up upon
temporarily if you're going to draw the
houses last opportunity to do it up upon
so now we're playing an endgame even
material this is weak and this is weak
so who's going to arrive first
maybe objectively this is a draw for the
players a long time so somebody might
arrive first who is going to who's going
to do so I'm not sure Magnus has a more
active king but the a pawn also runs
pretty quickly I mean King up King up
push we might be headed to a draw here
if Magnus draws Benjamin Bach has a
realistic chance of catching up to rule
Trinity Magnus Carlsen and making this a
very close race super kf5 push push push
push the pawn Oh
91 91 and you cannot stop this from
cleaning even the white gets his own
Queen Carlson is going to have a queen
first and he's going to have the first
chance to throw checks as opponent
Magnus Carlsen once again emerges ahead
in an endgame he calculate that so
beautifully he's one move ahead and
that's all it takes to check mate with a
queen rook in the knight on the board
Queen check here I assume this is
winning he's gonna have to find it if he
does
check-check everything looks pretty good
yeah we have a checkmate approaching
guys queen f2 rook e1 Queen c2 is May
Queen d3 Queen c2 that's checkmate
Carlsen moves to 7 and a half out of 8 a
really really nice sequence low on time
he is the one who found the most precise
moves and he was faster maybe black
I mean maybe white had to consider
sacrificing quickly for this pawn and
then trying to win black's rook for his
a pawn
maybe rook g1 was the move maybe rook to
one I'm not sure some calculation but
with low time
Carlson's instincts held up and